what people forget is that we are on a
little ball floating in a very dark
hostile scary place
space you know and we're all if you like
Earthlings on this little planet to me
those animals have every right to exist
on this planet and to wash you know to
just see them disappear an absolute
tragedy of it beep it's probably one of
the worst things that can ever do you
know - just snub out a form of life a
species that's evolved over hundreds of
thousands of years just because of our
short termism so it it's its right to
exist is paramount you know we should
cherish these things as the ultimate
treasures of the planet you know every
spirit life is only possible because of
the diversity of life on Earth anyway
and Nature doesn't do redundancy you
know if s if if if something's redundant
in an ecosystem it generally doesn't
last very long there's been an awful lot
of natural selection to get us to the
point we are now already there's more
chance of that natural selection being
able to protect or keep the right things
in the right places if there's more
diversity to start with you know
reducing any amount of species reducing
any amount of animals or removing
populations is only going to make this a
weaker planet so you're going to make
the resources weaker for the people who
depend on it and the animals that depend
on it if we look at this some planet
that we live on this ball floating
around it's got this fantastic
regulating system that regulates the
climate the water the air all these
things that we take for granted but the
notes and the bonds of the system are
the species within it the pide tamarins
for example the black line the fish
they're all part of the machine that
keeps us on this habitable planet so if
we start chucking away the nuts and
bolts I almost start disappearing
ultimately you know from a selfish point
of view that's gonna have an impact on
us yeah that's kind of a massive impact
on us so from a altruistic point of view
of
that and the beauty and the wonder of
the planet yes these animals have to
survive but also from a selfish point of
view we have to have these animals and
these species on the planet we are
intrinsically linked our futures are
intrinsically linked and we've got to
grow up and just recognize that fact
this we're just fooling ourselves and
robbing future generations of humans who
live on this planet if we don't stop and
think now
you